ضغطات زر معدوده على هاتفك الذكي ويمكنك
ان تحجز رحله طيران الى ابعد نقطه على
الارض هذا ابرز ما تغير في ملامح السفر
خلال العقدين الماضيين بينما تستلقي على
فراشك يمكنك ان تخطط لرحله كامله وتنهي
كافه الحجوزات ومع ثوره طيران الاقتصادي
اصبح السفر متاحا للجميع اليوم يمكن ان
تقرا مراجعات او تقييمات الزوار لاي معلم
سياحي في اي مكان ومن اكثر من موقع اما
البرامج السياحيه فيمكنك ان تشاهدها عبر
مقاطع يوتيوب وتنتقل بين عشرات التطبيقات
لايجاد افضل عروض الاقامه في الفنادق ومدى
قربها من مركز المدينه قبل عشرين عاما كان
يمكن ان تتحدث مع الاسره عبر الهاتف
لدقائق معدوده بعد باهضه الثمن اليوم يمكن
ان تتواصل مع احبتك بالصوت والصوره على
جبل
الذكاء الاصطناعي دخل في الصوره وخلال
العشرين سنه المقبله ربما يخطط رحلاتنا
وحده بناء على تفضيلاتنا وشخصياتنا
سنوات وسنوات من الحلقات في صباح العربيه
سافرنا مع البرنامج الى اشهر الاماكن
السياحيه والاثريه تعرفنا على ثقافات
وحضارات مختلفه صباح العربيه دائما حول
العالم نتابع
[موسيقى]
انا مدى اعوام عرفنا صباح العربيه على
شعوب العالم من خلال رحلات سياحيه عبر
القارات هناك في الامريكيتين مرورا بغابات
الامازون واوروبا التاريخيه واسيا
بحضاراتها المتنوعه وافريقيا بسهولها
الخلابه
وحيواناتها البريه والقاره الاستراليه
اقصى جنوب الكره الارضيه باختصار جميع
اسقاع الكره الارضيه
[موسيقى]
في فقره سياحيه مميزه دخلنا مطابخ وجلسنا
على موائد عده واحيانا كانت الاطباق تطهى
في البريه قبل ان يتم اصطياد مكوناتها
تعرفنا على ثقافات من خلال طقوس مختلفه
كتناول الشاي في اليابان او من خلال رقصات
شعوبا واعراق تقليديه هنا شويه في
الارجنتينيه وهنا تنزانيا الافريقيه وهذه
ايطاليا القديمه وهذه جبال الهملايا في
نيبال في برنامجنا الصباحي زرنا اهم معالم
بلدان هذا الكون وشاهدنا شروق وغروب شمس
خلابين لكي يبدا مشاهدنا يومه بنشاط
وحيويه في صباح عربيه مشرق ليث بزاري
ينضم الينا من باريس مراسل صباح العربيه
ليث بازاري ودائما يا ليث يا زين عيشتك
دائما وابدا اهلا بك كيف كان تجربتك
السياحيه وانت تعد كل هذه التقارير من
اماكن سياحيه واثريه مختلفه حول العالم
يا زين عيشتنا كلنا اليوم بالعيد العشرين
للعربيه على كل حال شفت الزميل ابراهيم
بدر معنا بالموجز تذكرت حادثه بدها تاخذ
منه عشر ثواني بس كان عندي مباشر من
الحدود الرومانيه الاوكرانيه وكنا عند نهر
الدانوب وعلى بالنتظر المباشر كان في سفر
لاجئين ورانا واذا بسالني ابراهيم عن
السفن بس للاسف كانت هالسفينه عابره فراحت
بقول انا لابراهيم كما تشاهد خلفي السفينه
واللجوء للاسف ما كان في سفينه ولا كان في
لجوء كان بس نهر الدانوب هاي الحادثه
تذكرتها وتشوف لارا قبل شوي برضو معنا
بالمباشر في احد المباشرات على صباح
العربيه برضه في السياحه كنا في كينيا كل
المناطق خضراء بتذكر كان منتج البرنامج
الزميل ماجد ابراهيم واذا بنحكي عن انه
الخضار
سالا كيف الوضع عندكم اخضر ولا احمر
بالاسواق هاي بس تذكرت زملاء لانه شويه
الاقتصادي
حالنا بكثير من المرات واحنا بنشره
الاخبار لما تكون انت ختام التقرير يا عم
تعمل لك حركه ناطت من هون ولا عم تاكل من
هون ولا عم ترقص مع قبيله ما
بعادات غريبه لافته كمان برضو بنتذكر قديش
حاولنا نمسك حالنا وما نضحك كمان
صحيح ما كانت سهله وهو هيك الواقع يعني
هذا لسه احنا طلبوا مني احضر كواليس
بصراحه انا طلع على الهوا بتوقع احلى من
الكواليس اللي حضرناها لانه كانت تلقائي
وبتعرف لما تكوني مباشر نادين وسهام بيكون
شي طبيعي ما بتقدر تتحكمي فيه وما في مجال
انه نعمل ممتاز او نقصر او نطول باللقطه
طب انت شو ماسك يا ليث عندي فضول
شو ماسك بايدك
هاي لما صورنا لما صورنا لما صورنا
بصلاله بتذكر بمنطقه جبل استمحار وبهديك
المناطق هاي كانت هديه احتفظت فيها في
اشياء كثيره مثلا هون الشماغ السعودي من
كتر ما هو عاجبني لحد هلا ما لبسته
متخيلين مخليه بالباكيه بالعلبه تبعته حتى
استعمله مش رح نحكي اسم الماركه لانها
مشهوره كتير بالسعوديه على كل حال بدي
يعني اذا حكينا على المناطق العربيه
زرناها كثيره ما بنسى مثلا زياره تونس قطر
المغرب الاردني الكويت السعوديه السعوديه
على فكره المناطق التي ابهرتني بصراحه
فيها مناطق مختلفه اذا حكينا عن الباحه في
جنوب الجنوب الغربي من اقليم الحجاز شفنا
المزارع الجميله الينابيع العذبه
المغامرات الجبليه قبلها المره ركبنا من
التادفه في جبال القلب ولكن اول مره كانت
في جبال الثروات في السعوديه ما بننسى
طبعا رحله الدراجه من شمال المملكه منطقه
الحقل الحجل عند الحدود الاردنيه مرورا
بينبع وجده والقنفذه والليف الى جزر فرسان
اقصى جنود المملكه يعني اكثر من
كيلو متر زرت شواطئ لم تطاها قدم ومناظر
كانت خلابه يعني عن جد تحبس الانفاس على
طول الساحل الغربي لاكتشاف شواطئ السعوديه
اللي هي هلا اليوم منطقه نيويورك احنا
زرناها كان لسه المشروع ببدايتو لسه ما
كان واضح فهذا كانت المناطق وما بنسى طبعا
القصيم يعني لن انسى سوق
السوق الشعبي الذي يقع وسط محافظه عنيزه
وزيارتي طبعا لمدينه بريده ومتحف العقيلات
وقريه المذنب التراثيه التي يعود تاريخها
لاكثر من 700 سنه متخيله يعني مقصوره
السويلم هي عباره عن قصر التراثي كبير
يعود بناؤه الى مطلع القرن التاسع عشر هاي
اشياء ما بتنتسى انا يعني زياره السعوديه
لن بعدين الشاطئ نصف القمر في المنطقه
الشرقيه
عده مناطق كان لنا يعني الحظ عن طريق
العربيه وصباح العربيه نزور هذه المناطق
وبقيه العالم منطقه اغرب المناطق منطقه
القصيم المخطوطات التراثيه والقصور
التاريخيه بقيه العالم يعني حكينا انه
شروق الغرب شروق الشمس من الغرب وغروبها
من الشرق في بنما لانه يعني جغرافيه بنما
شفنا انه كيف كانت
الجغرافيتها هي تقع عشان هيك في قناه بنما
تقع بين المحيط الهادي والمحيط الاطلسي
فعند الشمس عن جد هي بلدي الوحيده بالعالم
عكس الكره الارضيه من ناحيه الشروق
والغروب واذا حكينا عن اللغات قبل شوي
حكيت في العناوين كيف ان اللغات بتصير
مختلفه انا اول مره بسمع لغه الاجزابيث هي
قبيله في تنزانيا بحكوا بكلاك لانجوج
language يعني اللغه الكلاك
ما في ما في احرف ما في كلمات فهيك عن جد
استغربنا انه كيف طريقه كلامهم وك يف
بتواصلوا مع بعض وهاي شعوب عاده القبائل
هي من اقليات القبائل اللي ما بعيشوا ولا
بمغر ولا ببيوت يعيشون في الطبيعه يعني
وين ما بيوقفوا وين بلاقوا اكل بقعدوا تحت
الشجر بيقعدوا اكمن يوم ثم ينتقل الى
مناطق اخرى وطبعا عدا عدا اليابان وما
ادراكم
اليابان وتاريخ اليابان العريق والغريب
ههه